so it's with a great pleasure I'm here
today to show to you our latest creation
it's a very unique car for a Koenigsegg
or any brand I would say as it's
probably the only combustion engine
sports car that I know that doesn't have
a transmission at all it's direct drive
from the combustion engine to the rear
wheels it's the American debut of the
estimated two million dollar Riera this
is the two-door hyper car we saw in
Geneva earlier this month but this is
the first time it has ever hit us shores
some people are calling it the Bugatti
killer
the 1500 horsepower yarra combines three
electric motors with a regular engine
and a super new progressive
configuration that uses no gearbox and a
unique direct drive system that has
replaced the traditional transmission
that means it's super light and is
virtually seamless as it screams to 200
miles per hour in fact according to
Koenigsegg it will be able to sprint to
62 miles per hour in 2.8 seconds and hit
a top speed of 248 miles per hour that
is fast although it's not nearly as fast
as the bugatti chiron reported 288 miles
per hour top speed and 2 second flat
sprint time but maybe we're getting
ahead of ourselves
let's see them both on the road look for
the Riera on sale at the Manhattan
motorcars dealership later this year the
plan is to build 80 of them you better
be quick